Yo tout l'monde c'est Squeezie aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur Chrome Experiment
Je sais le "Yo tout l'monde c'est Squeezie"  vous avait manqué il est de retour !
Aujourd'hui on est sur Chrome Experiment c'est un site web qui regroupe des sites web innovant
Eh qui sont donc des sites web du futur, voila
On a une liste il y a 1199 sites web répertoriés
Dont certains qu'ont l'air extrêmement bien on commence avec Home Music Club c'est partie
Qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel
*Bruit musicaux*
Putain le futur eh c'est beau !
Nan franchement le futur *bruit de triangle* oh attend
Pardon, nan le futur c'est génial !
*Bruit musicaux*
Bon vous savez quoi on se retrouve dans une heure quand j'aurais finis de jouer avec ce putain de site
Et on passera à la suite
Pardon excuser moi en fait j'ai compris
C'est la que tu fais les notes en fait
Par exemple
Play ! *Musique bizarre*
Je suis une grosse merde !
*Musique africaine*
Bon voila si vous voulez jouer
avec euh...
de la musique pendant euh... des années
et finir au chomage
Aller sur ce site !
Infinite City alors ça !
Ah c'est genre une ville infinie
On va se balader dans une ville infinie c'est ça
Mais non !
Mais comment c'est possible
Eh nan c'est exceptionnel ce qu'il ce passe
Le futur est là mec
Pour de vrai c'est quand même dingue !
C'est un site web mec c'est pas un logiciel
Bon c'est chiant
*Rigole*
Voxel.CSS qu'est ce que c'est que ça
On va jouer avec un cube c'est ça ?
On va faire quoi avec ce cube, on peut le bouger
On peut, le modifier
C'est ouf parce que normalement ça tu n'aurait jamais pus le faire sur un site web normalement c'est des logiciels
de modélisation où tu fait ça
Et là tu peut vraiment modélisé un putain de cube sur un site web
c'est incroyable
Medusa eh ça à l'air beau mec
OOOH !!! C'est beau !!!
J'peut l'influencer nan ? Je peut juste changer l'angle de vue ?
Avec la petit musique euh... des abysses
Wouaw c'est beau, c'est fascinant, aller suivant !
Bon le futur il est cool mais....
Il est tranquille
tranquille
Oh qu'est ce que c'est que ça sa à l'air génial ça
play !
*Les hommes dans les cœurs font de la musique*
Et tu peut bouger les coeurs
Ah et du coup tu peut envoyer le [site] d'accord !
D'accord tu peut envoyer de l'amour !
Regarder comme je vous charme
"Pour mes abonnés d'amour"
C'est incroyable comment on pourra s'envoyer de l'amour comme ça dans l'futur
c'est...
c'est beau
ou c'est glauque *rigole*
One million stars
An online star register project
Ah d'accord... On part la dessus pour de vrai !
Beh attend c'est abusé !
Ohlala ! Le site du futur mec
Qui regroupe toute les étoiles !
Wouah mec c'est la galaxie !!
On est tout petit et là-bas il y a le soleil !
c'est génial !
Ou tu peux créer une étoile et comme ça elle sera visible
Attend on va créer une étoile
Attend ! il mendient sur ça !
D'accord il y a tellement d'étoile dans le ciel
Que tu peut payer 33$ pour donner un nom à une étoile
de ton choix
nan mais c'est *rigole*
'tain les business man ils savent plus où s’arrêter quoi !
Domino !
Nan !
Me dit.. Attend !
Mec je suis en train de trouver le site le plus...
Si ont peut faire ce que je pense
c'est l'site le plus orgasmique de tout les temps
*Bruit de dominos qui tombent*
*Orgasme de Squeezie*
Vous avez joui vous aussi !
C'est génial parce que ta le coté jouisif mais sans le coté ou t'est une bonne grosse merde comme ça à aligner tes dominos comme un bon puceau
mec celui la vas être incroyable
*Orgasme de Squeezie*
oh la spirale infernale ! *bruit chelou*
J'adore
constrain ça c'est chinois donc c'est compliqué c'est sur
Ils sont trop au-dessus de nous
Regardez, quelle est cette masse mec ?
C'est cool mais vraiment effrayant
C'est hyper stressant arrêtez ! laissez ma souris tranquille
Ok next !
Lightsaber escape ! c'est quoi ce délire ?
Pour commencer rendez vous sur [lien du site] sur votre téléphone
Ok
Pour activer votre sabre laser, vous devez d'abord calibrer votre téléphone
Vous êtes prêts à démarrer votre évasion
Attends mais meec! *rire*
Ca va bien marcher ou pas ?
Oh mon Dieu ! Oh mon Dieu ça commence !
Whooo!
Mais attends mais c'est abusé !
Mais attends mais c'est a..
Mais je pensais pas du tout ça possible !
*bruit sabre laser* mais mec c'est quoi ce..?
*rire*
google quel est ce..
*cri*
*bruits de lasers* tiens !
Hop là voilà ! *rire*
Venez là brigands !
Bri...brigadiers
Ca marche mieux que l'HTC Vive qu'est ce qui se passe ?
ooooooh !! whoooo!! ça part en couille !
*cri* ah c'est dur là !
Putain c'est super dur !
Ouais
Ouais vas y il me saoule lui lancer de sabre !
Nooooon !
Super je me suis enflammé mon skil de Jedi m'a dit de lancer le sabre
j'avais oublié que j'étais juste un puceau avec un téléphone dans la main *rire*
Bon du coup on a été capturé
*sonnerie téléphone* ah ! Google m'envoie un message
"Bravo ! Tu as été une énorme merde sur notre jeu "
Eh bah mec ! Si ça c'était pas un site web du futur !
Oh ! Smashing Mega Scene c'est quoi ça ?
Ah d'accord on tue un truc de sable
Mais attends c'est fantastique
Mais non
Mais si
Mais si c'est ce qui se passe
Regardez
brrrraaaaaa
c'est pas mal, c'est pas mal du tout ça me plait beaucoup
Sinon tu vas à la plage et en plus tu bronzes
Mais en vrai on se rend pas compte mais je pense que
Chaque site sur lequel on va c'est une putain de prouesse technique
Et vu qu'on est heu... un peu des merdes
On se rend pas trop compte
C'est quoi ça Deja Vu ?
Vas y photo ?
Are you ready to play with this face ?
Ok
Qu'est ce qu'ils sont en train de faire avec mon visage mec *rire*
Oula !
Oula ! C'est quoi ça ? *rire*
*musique du site*
*rire*
What the fuck ?
Arrêtez de danser on veut pas
On en a marre
En fait, *rire*
Ca a mal découpé mon visage et du coup ça a fait le truc avec mon oeil
Ce qui rend le truc hyper drôle *rire*
C'est cool !
C'est vraiment génial !
Mais pas avec mon oeil !
Putain génial meilleure expérience du monde
Firestarter ça ça m'interesse ça
Y'a un feu
Ok
Changer les paramètres du feu
Qui finalement ressemble plus à un amas de losanges
Qu'à un vrai feu voila
On a fait du....du feu
heu...et on est toujours puceau
Voici la Adventure Machine heu de Madeon
Un artiste français extrêmement doué
Ceci est génial c'est comme ce qu'on a fait toute à l'heure à la musique mais en mieux
Tu choisis un beat dans les carrés rouges
Par exemple ça ok *musique du site*
On se sent DJ ou pas alors qu'on a rien fait ?
*rire*
On a juste cliqué mais on se prend pour David Guetta
Ok la vous êtes prêts ?
On ajoute un bleu
*musique du site*
Attends je me prends pour un DJ
Et là attention
On rajoute un sample
*musique du site*
Et on re-rajoute un sample
Et voilà j'envoie du rêve
J'envoie du rêve alors que j'ai fait 5 cliques merci Madeon !
Elu site de l'année par Squeezie !
C'est un titre de merde Madeon mais c'est toujours ça
SpaceLand  qu'est ce que c'est que cette chose ?
Putain mais mec ! Vous vous rendez compte que maintenant on peut jouer à ça
Sur un putain de navigateur
Et faut qu'on chope des medikit et des popcorns
Et on veut attendre la Terre c'est génial
Hiiiiiihiiiiii
On arrête
Heu.. Trip Under The Moonlight
Mais noooon...
Mais non mais mec si je attends je peux avancer ?
Mais oui !
Regardez le futur il est pas beau ?
Non mais franchement ! Avoir ça dans un navigateur
Je me répète mais c'est vrai c'est fantastique
Lepracursor
Ah d'accord dès que je clique sur un lien bleu ça multiplie mon curseur
Et lequel est le bon du coup ? on sait pas
Oh !
whoooouuu
C'est la fête !
C'est génial !
Mais ça sert à rien
Distort
Qu'est ce que c'est que ça ?
Faut faire quoi ? Faut faut di.. faut di.. faut tordre la masse
C'est ça ? ouiii
C'est une boule antistress virtuel
Du coup ça destress pas du tout... voila !
Pigments c'est quoi ce truc encore de de de LSD là
Oh ! C'est comme le truc Star Wars  sauf que cette fois on va controlé son coeur
pour qu'elle reste en vie !
Attend j'adore, j'adore ce genre de jeu
Vous avez vu ? On dirait que je like des photos instagram mais pas du tout hein
Je la maintiens en vie
Si je fais rien
Elle meurt ?
Ah ! Elle est en train de mourir !
Ok et ça repart
C'est quoi ce clip bizarre là avec ce.. pourquoi tu mets du scotch de déménagement sur le visage ?
J'arrête !
Je sors de cette histoire
Verlet Spiderweb wtf ?
Waaaa ! Ah mais c'est horrible !
Qu'est ce qu'on fait en fait à cette ar... aaah aaah c'est horrible !
Mec j'aime pas du tout
En fait le but c'est de la faire sortir de sa toile mon gars
C'est du catch contre une araignée
Allez dégage dégage dégage dégage
Putain on est tellement mauvais que même une araignée elle nous met mal quoi
Ah mais tu peux pas la dégager mec c'est techniquement c'est  impossible
Attend on va la dégager comme ça !!! on va la déga...*rire*
Elle n'arrive plus à suivre *rire*
*bruit chelou* oh !
Oui ! je l'ai ! ouii !
Maintenant tu..nooon elle reste accrocher à sa toile !
Arrête !! Arrêeeeeeete de t'accrocheeeeeer !!
Ah! Ah! ça me répugne j'arrête
Voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur tous ces sites web du futur
Et croyais moi le futur
Ca va déchirer
Voila , c'est ma conclusion
N'hésitez pas à aimer si ça vous a plu
Puis on se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine
Si vous voulez une deuxième vidéo sur les sites web du futur
Parce qu'il en reste heu encore au moins 80 qu'on a pas fait
N'hésitez pas à me le dire
Je vous dit à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo portez-vous bien
Tchao tous le monde !
Peace <3
Et moi je retourne sur la Adventure Machine
*musique de la Adventure Machine*